THROUGH FOR CIZIKAS.
ALMOST CONNECTED.
>> Butch: SPENT SOME TIME OBVIO
THE MINORS.
>> Brendan: PLAYED 43PAGEAU.
LONG
O'REILLYES MATT MARTIN WITH A H
ON ROBERT THOMAS.
THIS HANDED OFF.
THE BLUES WITH A CHANCE
OVER SKATED BY KOSTIN.
HERE'S WAHLSTROM, A BREAK WAY O
ANOTHER.
SNEAKS IT SHORT SIDE ON
THIS PLAY.
YOU -- AN OPPORTUNITY ON THIS
PLAY.LMIERI WITH A SHOT.
ER ENOU
DISTRACTION, BINNINGTON IS
TRYING TOCT WITH THE STICK
SHAFT OF BINNINGTON AND I THINK
THAT MIGHT BE ENOUGH FRGUE HE'S,
BUT HE'S NOT, LOOKS TO ME LENGE
GOALTENDER INTERFERENCEE A
2-0, NEW YORK
>> Butch: WHAT A PLAY BY DOBSON,
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TOOR.
BINNINGTON WITH NO OPPORTUNITY.
THAT'S THE
CHANGE AND ISLANDERS KEEPING
EVERYBODY FRESH OUT THERE.
>> Brendan: BLUES COMING BACKre
SHORT-CHANGE THEM.
HERE
ISLANDERS BENCH, GOT A.931 FOR
NEAR SIDE FOR NE
WITH ROBERT THOMAS ON HIM.
HAD A TOUGH TIME GETTINGNELSON,
WHERE HIS
>> Brendan: POWER PLAY GOAL NEW
YORK.
>> Butch: SEE WHAT HAPPENS, TAKE
ANOTHER LOOK.
>> Brendan: PULOCK LET IT GO
FROM THE ER LOOK.
>> Brendan: LET'S GET AN NT.
IT'S UNDER REVIEW.
CONSIDERING ALL THIS.
THE PLAY IS UNDER REVIEW.
IF WAS BAT INTO THE NET
WITH A HIGH
ROBERT THOMAS
AND HE SCORES!
THAT'S ALL ROBERT THOMAS NEEDED.
THERE'S THE
O'REILLY.
BACK TO KRUG.
COULDN'T DRAG IT WITH CLEAR
BELIEVE.
TARASENKO WITH THE GREAT SHOT.